for nearly 70 years experimental planes
have been developed and flown here in
the Mojave Desert from the first sonic
boom in the x1 to tomorrow's ultra
efficient ultra-fast aircraft NASA is
developing the future of air travel one
explained at a time sometimes they do
look a bit odd
but the far-out designs and ideas
developed here have led to some of the
biggest advances in modern aeronautics
the x57 is our newest x-plane it's a
flight demonstrator for electric
propulsion technologies so we're using
battery power and electric motors to fly
our new experimental airplane it's an
all electric powered airplane or it will
be once it's fully built it has to be
one of the most bizarre looking planes
you will ever see in the skies with the
propellers all the way along the wings
but of course it's not actually in the
skies yet so the way the pilots are
testing it now and putting it through
its paces and extreme scenarios is in
this simulator
the first thing you'll notice when you
see our airplane is the distributed
electric propulsion technology or dep we
actually have 12 small motors spread out
along the leading edge of our wing the
electric motors will help keep the plane
aloft at low speeds by increasing the
smaller wings lift as these fixed tests
helped prove we expect to demonstrate
with this aircraft that we can use five
times less energy at high-speed cruise
flight than we normally do for
traditional aircraft that takes some
serious gear and we got a peek at some
of the planes hacked controls we had
basically had to come up with with a
system to for informing the pilot
basically the same things that he's used
to flying in terms of throttle control
and thrust if this is actually used in
in racecars
a digital display that we've adapted to
help inform the pilot basically the
various throttle settings that I'm
hoping that in this case green lights
mean good the x57 like many of its
predecessors may spell big changes in
aeronautics
and as this technology makes it into the
private sector it's going to
revolutionize the way that the public
uses aircraft the x-plane program
doesn't stop here this experimental
design which will get next designation
of its own if it's approved might lead
to incredibly fast and quiet trips
across the country this is a mobile
flight demonstrator the ability to fly
from New York to to LA and two and a
half hours we think will become a
reality here
now that's Concord speed but Concord was
only allowed to go supersonic
over the ocean because it's sonic boom
was well a loud boom this new design is
meant to begin a new era of quieter
supersonic transcontinental flights the
intention is to build a vehicle that's
about a hundred feet long and this has
some very unique features if you look at
the way the angles come into the
fuselage and the way the tail is
configured and the way the front end is
configured it's stunning the nose just
goes on four that's stunning the reason
why it's designed the way it is is so
that the pressure waves coming off of
this vehicle will will be minimal and by
the time they reach the ground we'll
have a really low pressure wave which
creates a low sonic boom nASA says a
demonstrator based on this design might
take off as early as 2020 and then just
a few years after that it's possible
that passengers could travel at Mach one
point four across the country just
imagine only one in-flight movie before
touchdown